jupiter is home to some big storms
like the massive great red spot which
has been swirling on the gas giant for
centuries
why don't we bring it to earth and see
what happens
how long would this mega storm rage
how would it blow the socks off every
other storm our planet has ever seen
and why would you want to be at the
center of it all
this is what if and here's what would
happen if jupiter's storm
existed on earth
the great red spot is the largest storm
in our solar system and it's responsible
for giving jupiter its iconic
great red spot
spanning 16 000 kilometers across this
storm is nearly one and a half times
wider than earth
and it reaches towering heights of
kilometers into jupiter's atmosphere
scientists have been able to observe
this storm for 200 years now
though it's likely that the storm is
much much older than that
more recently the great red spot appears
to be changing shape and shrinking
but whether it's getting smaller or not
how would this great storm look on earth
would our entire planet from surface to
space be blanketed in a storm that would
rage on forever
the great red spot isn't the only storm
on jupiter but hauling over all the gas
giant's storms would be a little too
devastating for our planet
you'd see massive cyclones on both the
north and south poles if you did
and those big bad cyclones would be
surrounded by several smaller cyclones
though smaller wouldn't mean much
compared to what you might be used to
they would have wind speeds that reach
up to
350 kilometers per hour and be about one
and a half times stronger than a
category five hurricane
the great red spot on its own would be
more than the earth could really handle
anyway
this storm is so tall that it would
reach the international space station
that's more than 400 kilometers straight
up
in total this massive storm would cover
about 40 percent of the earth's surface
and given what we already know about its
existence
it wouldn't appear to be going away
anytime soon
scientists observed that on jupiter the
great red spot usually hovers at the
same latitude that's because it's likely
held in place by two cloud bands in the
planet's mostly hydrogen and helium
atmosphere
if this happened here on earth the
unlucky countries that fall along this
line of latitude would be plagued by
this forever storm
imagine the great red spot perpetually
orbiting around the equator
if you lived somewhere like brazil
uganda or indonesia you'd have to be
constantly on the move
you'd need to stay within the eye of the
storm
or else
at least in there you'd be dealing with
some relative calm compared to what's
going on around it
on its outermost edges the winds of the
great red spot would reach speeds
between 430
to 680 kilometers per hour
even at the low end of that these winds
would be twice as fast as the strongest
hurricanes on earth
but what a sight it would be to gaze at
this storm from a distance
you'd see a tower of clouds reaching all
the way up to space wherever it hovers
it would block out sunlight potentially
lowering temperatures around the globe
not much within the storm's path would
stand a chance of survival
this goes beyond trees and your home
being swept away
skyscrapers and high-rises are the last
places you're going to want to be
it would release unprecedented amounts
of rain displace millions of people and
could result in a never-ending series of
devastating mudslides and floods
it would be so powerful that several
smaller but still devastating storms
could form around its edges creating
even more chaos
but could the great red spot really rage
on forever and ever
well thankfully on earth it likely
wouldn't
when large hurricanes form over warm
ocean water they pick up strength until
they make landfall
at this point they lose their primary
fuel source
moisture
on a gaseous planet like jupiter the
great red spot doesn't stop
because it doesn't have any continents
to collide with to rain on its stormy
parade
and while you may know this storm by its
iconic red color it wouldn't necessarily
stay red on earth
since our atmosphere mostly consists of
nitrogen oxygen and other trace elements
it could appear blue or whitish to you
so maybe it would be best to keep the
great red spot right where it is
you've already got enough to worry about
with all the destructive storms right
here on earth
speaking of which i wonder what it would
be like if the mother of all hurricanes
made landfall in new york city
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]